[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm very i'm just delighted that we have
oscar win vinberg here with us today
uh to um share some of his work on all
the family
oscar vinberg holds a phd in history
from [ __ ] academy university he's working
on a political history of television
entertainment in the 1970s united states
his work focuses on mass media and
modern political history and has
appeared in p.s political science and
politics european journal of american
studies and finx tid scrift
and now here's where we're going to run
up against the limits of my finish uh
he's a columnist for
please oscar could you say it
who would start it
that place
yes and has written for venues such as
made by history at the washington post
vasabladet
and the public broadcasting corporation
in finland
um so take it away oscar
thank you and and i do want to start by
noting that i would have loved to to
actually be in boston for this but uh
i'm i'm really happy that at least we
have the virtual options nowadays um so
i want to start by by congratulating you
all at mit um i know that you just
unionized so congratulations on on that
the grad students and and also
i know that tomorrow is the thesis
presentation day so there's a
congratulations on on making it that far
in the semester as well
um
so i'm just gonna start sharing my my
screen here um and go to the the
presentation
uh
let's see there we go
right
so
my
my dissertation and my work is focused
on on all in the family
um but it's really a bigger story about
television entertainment
uh and politics in the 1970s and beyond
and
and so today i'm going to focus on on
under the title of archie bunker ghost
washington on how television remade
politics into entertainment in this era
and the implications for american
politics
of this transformation
and so for the talk today
i'm going to start by giving the sort of
structures of broadcasting that you need
to know and understand for this story to
make sense and then we'll move into the
political structures
that enables television to have this
huge influence in the 1970s and and then
we'll get
into the campaigns and how um on the
family and television entertainment
was changing uh american politics will
go through electoral campaigns then into
legislative campaigns and end up with
grassroots campaigns and and then some
conclusions
at the end of that
so
to start off we need to understand how
broadcasting worked and looked um in
1970s united states and so by the end of
the 60s television was in something of a
paradigm shift in the middle of a
paradigm shift um les brown the
television writer know that the
established systems was
seriously troubled by economic
uncertainty harassment from washington
and the threats of new technology so
this is the last decade of what
television historians have called the
network era that stretches up until the
late 70s
and what
we mean by that term is of course that
the three television networks cbs nbc
and then the perennial loser abc
really dominated all broadcasting
and and and although they only were
allowed to own and operate five stations
um they really dominated the national
association of broadcasters and and and
thus the whole industry
but
as the case is the affiliate stations of
course is the first sale that the
networks make they're selling the
programs to the affiliate stations and
the affiliate stations then are running
it nationally and so
there's always um i feel a need to
highlight the role of the affiliate
stations in this and and often they also
had interests uh even if if their
economic interests trumped uh any
political interests
but then the the third part
that is critical to understanding this
story is the role of independent
producers in the 1970s um and this is
not just as it often is told it's a
story about norman lear being extremely
powerful
vis-a-vis the networks because of the
success of his shows not just all in the
family which was the most popular show
on television for five consecutive years
uh but he also had top 10 hits such as
as sanford and sun and
mod good times um later on the
jeffersons one day at a time and he was
really
printing cash for cbs in in the 1970s
but it's not just the story of of norman
lear being a a genius in television
production
it's more a story of structures again
and so
in the 1970s you just have new
regulatory action uh from the fcc um
which has pushed through what was called
often the westinghouse rule uh which
included two distinct regulations so the
the first one and the most important in
this
context was the financial interest and
syndication rule the second one was the
primetime access rule but both intended
to circumscribe the influence of of the
networks to reshape broadcasting and and
the importance of the financial interest
and syndication rules was that it
limited the amount the networks were
allowed to own of of the programs
which enabled independent production
companies such as grant tinker and mary
tyler moore's mtm enterprises and aaron
spelling and leonard goldberg's spelling
goldberg productions and then
pertinent to this talk especially norman
lear and bud york in stanton productions
and enable them to to rise to prominence
indeed later later explained that
without the fins in rules we might never
have been able to build the company we
built
and this is critical
to understand that that lear
had
a unique position as a producer in
relation to the networks and and that
enabled him to take certain stance
that
hadn't been taken before by by
television entertainers or producers
um which is key for for the whole story
and so
the second thing of course is the
the politics
let's see if
i can move over to the next slide
um
so when we get to the 1970s the new deal
coalition the coalition that had
guaranteed democratic dominance in
american politics since the 1930s and
which was in essence an economic
coalition crumbled under its own weight
and during the 1960s especially uh with
the tumult of the civil rights movement
this was a coalition that
included in the democratic party both uh
my
racial minorities and the segregationist
south so
naturally it sort of
crumbled during the 1960s and instead
gave way for coalitions built on
emotions identity and experiences
and along with
technological advances this shift then
transformed the united states from a
politics of parties to a politics of
personality one could say that it moved
from the age of the party machine and to
the age of the consultant
now
part of this
in terms of of the
sort of real lived experience of
political campaigns is that the
nominating process is opened up so uh in
the 1960s as late as 1968 hubert
humphrey was nominated as as the
democratic party candidate for president
without having run in a single
single primary
during during the year
um and and after that
the nomination process is opened up and
the primaries become much more important
which of course uh democratizes the
process but also gives in
special
weight to party activists who are gonna
you know volunteer and and actually
walk around the snowstorms in in new
hampshire trying to get
uh people to vote
um but it also opens up for media
campaigns and and turns media into a
even more important factor in in u.s
politics as
you campaign around the nation in in
state primaries and and and caucuses
and then the third part of of this
transformation is is a story about
fundraising um which especially becomes
important in the mid 1970s as as the
watergate scandal unravels and and
congress moves in to try to put limits
on on fundraising and and sort of make
it more transparent the system
which again uh makes individual donors
more important but also in a funny turn
of events makes hollywood more important
as
the money coming from hollywood isn't
viewed with suspicion
or the same suspicion as for example oil
money from texas that
fueled lyndon johnson's political career
and so the historian john farrell noted
that by the time tip o'neill rose to
speaker of the house in 1977
in too many places the democratic party
had been reduced to an organizational
shell replaced in its traditional
function by television campaign
technology and the personal appeal of
telegenic candidates
and this is
part of this process is why television
becomes important and part of this
process is also caused by television
okay so at this point um i'm going to
show you a little clip
of all on family just to give you a
sense
of the show if you're not familiar with
it from from before
let's see if i can
get to
the
there we go
anything interesting
oscar i think you have to share that
specific window maybe we're still seeing
your powerpoint window you're still
seeing the power slide okay let me hold
on and try to
let's see if we can
make it work
uh are you now seeing
archie bunker yes
okay
um
so archie
in this clip is meeting his
future son-in-law for the first time
this is an early season but it's uh
flashback episode
where he meets mike for the first
and time of the world
that's great on the american flag the
hell of them
all right i think they just don't like
the idea of america
fighting in the illegal and immoral war
that's right it's your free cut we shall
answer
well that would include me too mr bunker
into the eu
well what would all evenings
without protesters this country would
still have the same problems what
problems
the war the racial problem the economic
problem
[Music]
nitpick
let me tell you something mr bunker let
me tell you something mr stevie you are
a me
and me
[Music]
okay so and there you have the
origins of that
famous
phrase of of archie bunkers and calls
his son-in-law a meathead
but i also wanted to show that clip
because it gets to the point of how
political paul on the family was and and
that was really something new in
american television um
the 60s the sort of sitcoms of the 60s
were more likely to be about flying nuns
or talking horses or
um
you know andy griffith and
walking down to to the lake to fish with
his son
and so all the family represented
something completely new in television
entertainment and as it became the most
popular show on television it of course
uh
saw a bunch of imitators and and sort of
set the tone of a lot of television
entertainment in the 1970s
so
as all in the family becomes this
phenomenon
of television entertainment and
as
it rises to the top of of the ratings
and archie bunker becomes an icon
in american society
politicians start to turn to all on the
family and try to figure out how they
can use this show this character to
their advantage
and in electoral campaigns um this is a
pattern throughout the 1970s and and
beyond and the first one to really
recognize the power of archie bunker uh
is john lindsay the liberal the sort of
quintessential limousine liberal mayor
of of new york uh former republican who
in 1972 is going to run for the
presidential nomination of the
democratic party um he has a reputation
as strong on television he has a
reputation as being able to use
celebrity
supporters in his campaigns
robert moses calls him a matinee idol
robert wagner the former mayor of new
york says um in a
not so veiled uh reference to to lindsay
says i'm still not a movie star but then
new york is not a movie
and another challenger in in new york
mario pocaccino calls him the actor and
so lindsay really has this reputation of
of being a star on television but what
he uses archie bunker
or carol o'connor the actor playing the
role what he uses him for in his
campaign shows a keen understanding of
not just celebrity but of the show and
the character and how you can
sort of make political gains on that
connection that viewers have with their
favorite shows
so lindsay spokesperson explains that he
can't actually endorse him in character
that is carol o'connor can't endorse him
in the character of archie bunker but he
uses some language that will make it
recognizable
and indeed carol o'connor records these
television ads for lindsay um
and
he explicitly plays on the character he
blurs the lines between himself the
actor a very liberal actor
one should note and this very
conservative character that he's playing
on television one of the ads he starts
by saying hello i'm carol o'connor uh
but then he sort of moves into archie
territory both in how he speaks um and
puts a cigar in his mouth he says if you
are a young american listen to an
old-fashioned one and so he's really
portraying himself as that beloved
character and and not uh as as the actor
now martin nolan the political
journalist noted immediately following
these ads that they indeed tell a lot
about politics media manipulation and
american culture
now john lindsay if if anybody is
familiar with his 1972 run knows that it
wasn't successful
uh indeed when he told friends he was
going to run one of them said john
you're going to be a [ __ ] disaster um
so
lindsay uh abandons his campaign after
poor uh showings in in florida and
wisconsin
and many historians have sort of
neglected or or rejected the importance
of archie bunker as a part of the
politics
or the political campaigns by pointing
out that
he's this conservative character uh
spoke for the liberal lindsay and and
assuming that uh
since lindsay didn't go far um archie
bunker clearly wasn't
giving any sort of political weight to
the campaign
nixon however
disagreed
and especially nixon's campaign staff
dwight chapin one of of his strategists
in the summer of 1972
warned
the nixon campaign
in a memo
liberals created archie and look at the
power arch he has with that segment now
his main concern
was the attention and endorsement from
the actor could attract and especially
if he used that character as a part of
of the
endorsement
indeed chapin warned in the memo that
carol o'connor doing mcgovern
commercials is not an impossibility
and instead
nixon wanted to get the archie bunker
endorsement according to sources they
wanted to pay for the country just
before the election with photos of nixon
and archie bunker shaking hands
but obviously carol o'connor as i
mentioned was a liberal
actor and and never even considered
endorsing nixon um what has been lost
sort of to the
lost from the historical record is that
he did indeed campaign and make uh
make commercials for mcgovern in the
fall campaign against richard nixon
and
if we look at the press um and how they
how they pay attention to this we can
clearly see
that
mcgovern who was a shrewd campaigner and
had strong connections in hollywood
warren beatty was one of the sort of the
ghost of in the machine of his 72
campaign and he had
stars from uh
rock musicians to actors and television
stars all over his campaign but he
didn't want to use carol o'connor as
just another big hollywood star instead
he recognized what lindsay had
recognized before him and and that is
the the sort of working-class appeal of
the character and the strong connection
viewers had with the character
and the press
reinforced this
so
following the endorsement the press
reported archie bunker is casting his
vote for mcgovern an associated press
headline read archie bunker backs
mcgovern
political reporter walter mears of the
ap even highlighted the support of
archie bunker before that of former vice
president and mcgovern rival in the
primaries hubert humphrey
and in these commercials that o'connor
did he again plays on
his identity and the identity of archie
bunker so he starts the ad by saying
hello i'm carol o'connor a conservative
man speaking against radicalism against
the radicalism of the present
administration so even though the
support came from the liberal actor it
was a presented as an endorsement by a
conservative character
i as a conservative man o'connor
concluded i'm going to vote with
confidence for senator george mcgovern
now again i must stress o'connor wasn't
a conservative man at all he was a
liberal
but
he played
this most iconic conservative around in
1972 and and you see in the outtakes of
these uh advertisements that o'connor
really recognizes the need to
play himself as a conservative one of
the outstates he exclaims in frustration
when he
flubs a line never mind i got to get the
conservative in and in these 60-second
ads recorded he describes himself as
conservative again and again and
presents the nixon administration as an
example of radicalism again and again
now these were broadcast as part of
telephones where the candidate answered
questions from viewers and o'connor's
advertisements were hailed as the
catches won
now mcgovern himself introduced one of
them saying the only thing we ask is
that all of you who like archie bunker
vote for george mcgovern and sergeant
shriver
so you have the candidate himself
blurring these lines
um
now i'm gonna show you here another clip
and hopefully
the
share screening will
uh will work fine in this let's
[Music]
this is not
lindsay and it's not mcgovern it's a
little bit later it's a ted kennedy ad
from 1980
but it gets at the same
sentiment of how they're using carol
o'connor in the ads
friends herbert hoover hit up the white
house too responding to desperate
problems with patriotic pronouncements
and we got a hell of a depression but
i'm afraid jimmy's depression is going
to be worse than herbert's i'm
supporting senator kennedy because he's
out there facing issues inflation
sky-high prices and almost worthless
dollar unemployment
i trust ted kennedy i believe in them
in every way folks
kennedy for president
okay so in that
short clip you can see how he
tries to
get the viewers thinking about all in
the family by comparing jimmy carter to
herbert hoover in the opening of all
when the family
archie bunker sings about uh how we
could use a man like herbert hoover
again and so he's deliberately getting
the viewer to
think about the character as well as
well as how he's dressed as our two
bunker in that ad
so these early attempts by lindsay
mcgovern um and later by kennedy um
are examples of how
candidates who are good at
at television
who are
building their campaigns on television
have strong connections
in hollywood are familiar with celebrity
politics how they are using alma family
but it's not just a question of sort of
pioneers in showbiz politics turning to
to the character and and here we could
consider jimmy carter to understand the
importance of
archie bunker and and the way television
entertainment is changing
changing politics
so jimmy carter did not care about
hollywood at all um all of his aides
talk about how little value he saw in
courting and stars in in hollywood
but even if carter did not care about
hollywood the party the democratic party
cared about hollywood
and
carter himself when he visited
hollywood for fundraisers
at the beverly wilshire hotel
in 1976
told an audience full of stars such as
sidney poitier faye dunaway and carol
o'connor uh that he had a responsibility
to bypass the big shots including people
like you
and he didn't want to build his campaign
on on television stars or movie stars
and yet prominent stars campaigned for
the democratic candidate carol o'connor
teamed up with rob reiner in public
service television advertisements for
the voter registration drives of the
democratic party uh where the two
characters the two actors again played
the characters from the show and sort of
played on the
animosity of their characters and saying
like if you if people like you are going
to register and vote i'm going to
register and vote just to even the score
um
and then when carter comes into the
white house
you see
uh during the inauguration weekend these
events celebrating carter and
which again have a very solid emphasis
on television you have performances by
red fox from sanford and son freddie
prince from chico and the man and and
then gene stapleton and carol o'connor
from from all the family
um
and and indeed
carter's uh strategists become convinced
that they have found something special
in hollywood and in television and
even go so far as
kind of naively exclaiming that no one
in the white house before has ever
treated television as a great american
institution
only months into carter's tenure norman
lear is on the phone to the white house
to offer his help
to get the democrat in the white house
to
sort of use television
for his
for his own benefit and and to make him
um succeed in in governing
so
the electoral campaigns are showing
signs of going beyond traditional
celebrity politics or showbiz politics
and incorporating the show and playing
on the connection of uh
of the show and how the viewers relate
to the characters uh intentionally
blurring the lines between entertainment
and news between fact and fiction
the same pattern is evident in
legislative campaigns
so here we're going to look at some
liberals on capitol hill
we're going to look at peter rodino and
herbert harris uh
we're going to look at frank church
we're going to lose holtzman
and their attempts to use the show on
capitol hill um
to promote a certain agenda
so
frank church is is really the first uh
first per first
member of congress to turn to all in the
family to promote an agenda
so frank church he's a rather media
savvy uh senator and and he
serves as the chairman on the committee
on aging
and when all in the family
features an episode in which edith the
wife of of archie bunker uh finds an old
man who has escaped from a
nursing home and come
and invites him into her house
until he can find a permanent
uh
permanent residence with his girlfriend
in fact
the show
features explicit debates around uh
the situation of the elderly in the
united states and indeed the director of
the show
had experiences with his own mother
aging that he wanted to incorporate into
the show and and and make make the show
tackle uh a
issue of importance and relevance in in
american life at the moment
so
frank church then uh
coordinates with the production company
and especially with a woman called
virginia carter who is brought into the
production company to handle these sort
of political relations
and then
he is able to use that connection to
promote
ideas around aging that he shares with
the with the writers and producers of
the show
at an elite audience in washington so
in his role as chairman of the committee
on on aging uh church invites his
colleagues and a selection of
high-profile champions for the elderly
to an advanced screening of the all in
the family episode in washington which
is organized in coordination with with
tandem productions
the guest list included prominent
authorities on social security and aging
such as arthur fleming eisenhower's
former secretary of health education and
welfare
there was jack oszowski
of the national council on aging and
edwin kaskowitz of the gerontological
society
and
and and of course the entire committee
on aging
and
he screens this episode to illustrate
in a
in an engaging manner these sort of
challenges facing the aging and
following the screening that the
senator's staff then requests the script
to circulate among members of the
committee who missed the event it was
scheduled at the same time as watergate
hearings and so
they wanted to make sure everybody's
getting the point here um
and also
also making sure that
viewers reactions and viewers letters to
the production company was forwarded to
the senate staff and and then circulated
among these audiences and then uh church
takes to the floor of congress to praise
the episode and in fact he says that
they they made many of the points which
the senate committee on aging and i as
its chairman attempt to make in reports
and speeches
then he highlights some of these saying
the special impact of high food costs
upon the elderly the fact that medicare
covers only 42 percent of the health
care costs of older americans and the
fact that the average social security
benefit is less than the official
poverty level
so a very sort of detailed
political discussion taking place on
prime time most popular show on
television and then
is being used on capitol hill
now rodino and harris together with
elizabeth holtzman
who has introduced
rape shield legislation in congress a
little bit later in in 1977
take
a page out of church's playbook and they
again collaborate with the production
company to show an episode um an episode
called uh eve it's 50th birthday in
which the character of edith bunker
faces a
sexual assaulter in her house
and they use that show which generates a
lot of attention um to promote this rape
shield
bill that is pending in congress so
again they
coordinate with virginia carter at
tandem productions
to organize an advanced screening in
washington
that is attended by legislator advocates
and volunteers at local rape crisis
centers
harris and rodino also connect with
tandem productions to have gail
abarbanel who
works at the santa monica rape treatment
center and who had
sort of consulted on on the process of
of making the episode um speak at this
event
um and and indeed she praises the
episode saying it's a warm and caring
portrayal of the impact of this crime on
a victim and her family and it can
stimulate the kind of open discussion of
the true nature and ramifications of
rape that we have only recently been
able to do with breast cancer and
similar hidden major problems
now at this event um virginia carter
attends and acknowledge
that the intention when they're doing
these shows
is to entertain you to make you laugh to
educate you and make you cry
so again these legislators are turning
to entertainment because of the
connection people have the stories they
know these characters and the the
experiences of uh edith bunker being
threatened with sexual assault in her
own house
is
hitting the audience in a way that
uh hearings in washington
do not necessarily do on on a regular
basis and and that's why they're
turning to
a popular entertainment show
now we're going to move on to the
grassroots campaigns and and here we
have gene stapleton speaking at an equal
rights amendment rally and we're also
going to
mention carol o'connor being part of
these events as well as other television
stars such as valerie harper
from the mary tyler moore show alan alda
of mash and ed asner also of of the
married tyler moore show
so when the show premiered in 1971 the
character of edith bunker was
pretty much dismissed in reviews as sort
of a dim-witted wife
and even francis leer the feminist wife
of the producer norman lear acknowledged
that she initially wasn't sure of edith
bunker at all
and this was a challenge to to the
writers the writing room was almost
exclusively male at this point and
but they wanted to be a part of the
conversation and norman lear himself uh
identified as a as a feminist and wanted
to make sure that they
sort of stay
stay on the women's movement and keep up
with with the changes in society
so what he does is he hires virginia
carter from the national organization
for women to the production company she
has no experience of television and her
role is to make sure
that the scripts sort of deal with these
subjects
in a way that is
promotes an agenda
excuse me
so over the years
eve bunker
edith bunker develops into
into a feminist icon
um
she refuses to always assume the
subservient role the character finds job
outside of the home she even challenges
her husband
and asserts herself in the home
and
uh
generally critical report on women and
minorities on television by the united
states commission on on civil rights
by the end of the 70s acknowledge that
edith bunker stands up to archie in
defining what is right and wrong
so
they start changing that character and
how she's written and and how she
engages on the show with these kinds of
issues
and as they does that the
the character becomes this icon and and
indeed gene stapleton becomes a
political figure in her own right
now in sharp contrast to carol o'connor
and rob reiner who both came to the show
with
with strong liberal politics jeanne
simpleton
described herself as a fairly apolitical
person
and and talks about
al already in 1972 talks about or
expresses a belief and a hope that her
character does not represent the average
woman in in the united states
but in this environment of of liberals
and feminists at the production company
stapleton
finds herself as a part of the women's
movement
and she describes this as finding
himself herself in this nest of
activists out in l.a
and so she became an activist in her own
right and and indeed a key alley ally in
in the fight for the equal rights
amendment
now the equal rights amendment is passed
by congress in 1972 sent out to the
states for ratification
and becomes this key political struggle
of the 70s and especially something of a
cause celebrity for for uh
for hollywood liberals but there is also
swift mobilizing in in opposition most
notably by by phyllis schlafly and the
stop era
movement
and
what the
proponents of the era recognize early is
the the value of celebrities so at these
um
rallies
and gatherings you often find television
stars i've already mentioned harper and
alba and asner
there's also from happy days henry
winkler takes part in these uh charlie's
angels kate jackson so these are clearly
not very political shows happy days and
charlie's angels
and yet you have the actors out there um
campaigning for the amendment
but
gene stapleton brings something
particular to the issue and she brings
the
character of edith bunker so even if
it's a
fictional
representation she brings the
perspective of a housewife
to the movement
and
is appointed by president ford and then
reappointed by president carter as a
commissioner on the national commission
on the observance of international
women's year which
gives her even more prominence in these
circles and and she
carefully researches the issues ahead of
interviews she works with activists
and and just to get the stuff right
because she knows that she's she's
getting opportunities and she's getting
media coverage that not everybody has
the opportunity to get
she goes on talk shows at rallies
but in stark contrast to
valerie harper or carol burnett
she's able to connect her activity to
the character the beloved character
of edith bunker so
she usually connects it by talking about
the character she says of course
uh
edith bunker would support gratification
of the 27th amendment to the
constitution because it is a matter of
simple justice and edith is the soul
justice
and she even goes as far as as
doing advertisements
uh in the voice of edith bunker and in
contrast with other actors she refuses
on all talk shows to do the edith voice
or or appear as edith but in these uh
ads for the era she says as edith bunker
i don't have equal rights as gene
stapleton's i don't either uh
and and she talks about being archie's
lovable dingbat on all the family and
and saying that it's not a
it's not a laughing matter to be treated
like a second-class citizen
um
and
promotes the era
in person and in advertisements and
again she's using that not
not necessarily as a hollywood actress
but as the character
so some conclusions from this and how
this is changing u.s politics now of
course mcgovern didn't win in 1972.
uh frank church didn't succeed in his
crusade for bold new welfare legislation
and the feminists fighting for the era
also faced defeat
so clearly all in the family isn't some
sort of a magic silver bullet that will
just change politics or convince
voters
but what it does instead is that it
changes
politics as
as it
engages educates promotes mobilizes and
organizes not only voters
but
legislators and indeed donors as well um
and and in this way it sort of
changes how television works and
promotes these changes to
uh to the structures of politics of the
way campaigns work of the way
institutions work and of the ways
campaigns work
so you have
this change that is making show
politics into some sort of show business
where it's dependent on the same
consumer demands it's getting media
driven
celebrity or personality focused it's
getting to be
demands of of entertainment in politics
of itself and you see this as well with
with the watergate hearings where you
have people calling into the networks
and suggesting that you know bring back
john dean or some other witness or you
could change a storyline here or there
that the lines that divide politics from
entertainment are rapidly blurring in
the 1970s and part of the reason they
are blurring is because
politicians and
actors producers are intentionally
blurring them to promote their agenda
to promote their candidates and and to
promote
their legislation
so at this point i want to thank you all
for for following along and i invite you
to come
with questions
thank you i'm gonna we usually do a plus
at the end i'm gonna do it right now um
in particular i didn't mention this at
the beginning but you know oscar
he's in finland and he's doing this from
midnight to 1 30 in the morning so thank
you so much uh for for that um do we
have any questions i've got like
a dozen questions on my notepad here so
i don't but i don't want to take over do
we have any questions uh lined up out
there
besides mine
ready to
go i do have one
from uh ed shapa who uh was not able to
attend today but he wrote ahead
and i'm gonna read it to you he says i'm
sorry i'm unable to attend your talk but
i wanted to ask about the causal claim
embedded in this sentence from your
abstract very specific television
entertainment in the 1970s thereby
remade political life and its image
paving the way for our current moment of
mediated showbiz politics that's the
quotation
and ed asks i wonder what you make of
neil postman's theoretical argument and
amusing ourselves to death that it is
the epistemology of television that is
the enabling agent here that is is the
medium itself that turns us into
spectators and content into
entertainment the three tv shows you
mentioned i think he's referencing all
the family mash and mary tyler moore
show are symptoms of a much larger
historical phenomenon one that lance
strait has updated for the digital age
in his work amazing ourselves to death
neil postman's brave new world revisited
well i would say that that
that's a great question and it brings up
these sort of larger uh larger
questions around entertainment and and
how these developments come and
i guess at a media seminar marshall
mcloone is gonna pop up at some point
but the question of of whether the
medium is the message and and stuff like
this um i would say that in my research
what i've found is that
we should pay attention to these
structures and especially as michael
schutzen uh notes that
the power of television
does not come from the technology of
television it comes from this conviction
of people in washington that television
matters and and this is something that i
go into more detail in the dissertation
is that with all in the family these
conversations around television
entertainment move from the television
pages uh and from the talk shows uh into
the op-ed pages and and you see people
engaging with television i'm talking
here about uh political elites engaging
with television because they become
convinced and it's also uh you know the
third person effect in that they become
convinced not that we
are
falling for all in the family or like we
are manipulated by entertainment but
it's also always the other people like
the common people are uh very
susceptible to these appeals of of
entertainment um so i guess my
my answer would be that i would point at
these
individual actors in individual
campaigns that are turning to
to entertainment television and how they
reckon with the power of television
rather than
finding the explanations
in the medium itself
especially as we look at the 1970s which
is clearly a transformation period in
this larger
sort of transformation that he's
referencing
so
i mean do you see on the family is
signaling a kind of sea change in so far
as people think are thinking about the
effects of television
in
positive terms as opposed to strictly
negative it makes children violent or
children's attention spans
um
and also outside of i mean i think that
previously the way that tv was spoken of
in positive terms was often around a
kind of notion of uplift of artistic you
know if you could get more opera and and
uh more picasso on tv and less uh
my mother the car the common whipping
boy people who
hate tv in the 50s and 60s um that we
could elevate the taste standards of
americans this sort of thing or even uh
some of the things that newman points to
in the vast wasteland speech
do you think all in the family is a kind
of
pivot text for that new way of
conceptualizing tv in a positive light
well i would say yeah yes um in in many
ways and and this is something that you
see with
with all the family and
the telemark show and then
as they
gain popularity is that you see
more and more attention uh if if
television was seen as lowbrow before
you get this idea of quality television
this especially refers to to the mtm uh
enterprises and their productions not
just mary tyler moore but also bob
newhart show and other shows like that
uh in that
uh cultural elites try to make a
sort of
separation between the lobro brow of
television and then this quality
television to sort of make it acceptable
for themselves and and this is something
that is also critical in the development
of pbs at the same time period
so i would say that that
it's
very important in
that it allows
it allows a broader public to view it as
sort of respectable and to watch
television and a lot of this is is
driven by cultural elites by cultural
critics um who are making exceptions uh
for this kind of these kind of shows
and i should also note that the early
conversation the earliest conversations
around all in the family
focus almost exclusively on the issue of
prejudice and the question of whether
this bigoted character is
making it
better in the u.s by ridiculing
prejudices and racism or if he's making
it acceptable
to engage in such behavior in such
language and so there is this
conversation about oh my god what is
this show doing to our society as well
uh but
it soon becomes so popular uh that the
conversation sort of shifts to
wait a minute uh if everybody's
embracing this and like falling for it
how can we um as politician or political
actors uh
make
it work for our benefit
and that takes us to nixon i'm just
going to remind people in our attendee
group that you can type in questions
into the chat for us
um what you were just saying about this
sort of you know initial concerns about
is this making bigotry more acceptable
or you know is this appealing to
conservatives not just liberals and so
on uh brings me back to the part of the
talk where you talk about nixon
seriously considering you know could
this guy could carol o'connor do
advertisements for me
and
um
i mean of course he would do anything to
get elected pretty much but is he
does he understand to your mind you see
understand it's satire but
does he just think well most people
aren't going to get that because they're
not as smart as i am they'll be fooled
but you know like he he sees that it's
satirizing conservatives right
right uh and nixon sees it uh and indeed
nixon comes across all in the family and
sort of by happenstance he's he's
watching a ball game and it's rained out
and they're airing a rerun of of all in
the family and and that's where you get
this famous tape because obviously he
was he was um
recording every conversation in the oval
office but you get this date that has
been shared on social media and other
sort of venues uh where he rants about
the show because it it makes the hard
hat archie that is uh look bad and and
and also in his view it glorifies
homosexuality it's a show where archie's
uh very sort of masculine and viral uh
friend is revealed to to be gay um and
and much of the scholarly conversation
on on nixon and and all the family has
sort of focused only on this
conversation where he's angry and and
his
aides especially haldeman and erlickman
are sort of
playing on his anger and and agreeing
and talking about like one of them has
been following the show and says that
this is a theme like they're making fun
of you and and your supporters uh on
this
show um
but then the other conversation nixon
had about the show sort of tend to have
been
fallen out of of the historical record
and and i found that the most
interesting ones are
conversations he has with aids about the
show where he's actually laughing
at uh archie bunker and he's laughing at
norman lear and here it's it's reason to
remember that nixon had very close
friendships in hollywood uh especially
with the conservative uh
comedy producer paul keyes
who he had a relationship going back to
to the 62 campaign
and and
apparently in conversation with keys and
other friends in in hollywood he has
become convinced by by 1972 has become
convinced that
even though the producers are out to get
him and ridicule him it's not working
it's backfiring so he's drawing on this
public conversation that rages
throughout 1971 about whether
the show the agenda of ridiculing
bigotry is working or not uh and as he
becomes convinced of this he indeed
starts to hail archie bunker and see him
as uh as an a or
an endorsement
of his politics and somebody who makes
it acceptable or even popular and to
espouse the values of of nixon's silent
majority and hold them in one
conversation i think it's holderman even
exclaims that archie bunker is the best
advertisement we could have
ever done
and so
that's that's why and that's how nixon
comes to embrace archie bunker and then
why they attempt so um strongly make an
attempt to win over carol o'connor and
and indeed again drawing on those
connections in hollywood tries to
pressure o'connor to to endorse
archibald
to endorse richard nixon
[Music]
um
i mean bless you for uh finding all the
references to all the family in the
nixon recordings and you're absolutely
right most people point to that one
comment about the the gay character who
briefly appears on that one episode of
the show
um and
have no idea that there are other
moments when all the family comes up in
these white house discussions it's kind
of amazing i'll just put in a plug for
the documentary
experimental documentary r nixon uh
which uses that
um
audio to to gray effect and it's a
terrific film um
i wonder if you could
uh talk more about lin john lindsay
and why
his campaign failed
is it because it's too early in the rise
of this celebrity politics and the shift
that you're talking about both 68 and
the move from the political machine to
the sort of age of the consultant
and the the politics of party the
politics personalities you put it um
because
on the one hand from a strictly
political perspective on paper of course
lindsay should have lost because he
couldn't control the unions in new york
and in other words he had made mistakes
in new york city that showed that he
wasn't qualified to be president perhaps
right but on the other hand if celebrity
had already become this so important
which i i think it had i mean that was
part of how he got elected because he
was just really handsome and people
compared him to the kennedys all the
time and he
um
you know like i mean robert moses who at
that point must have been maybe a
hundred years old uh you can imagine his
horror that this matinee idol as he put
it was was mayor and so on
um
so
you know
especially with carol o'connor actually
doing ads for him like
i'm not saying that would be enough to
carry the white house but he really got
wiped right in florida um and i guess
also in wisconsin right yeah um
and
should he not have done better or is it
really just that this is too early and
he's like a prototype that failed and
then we have these other
versions of this new invention that win
well i think there's there's two
sort of
main factors to to consider and the
first one is that
john lindsay
is joining the democratic party in 1971
only months before he announces his his
campaign for the
nomination of president he's joining the
party that he wants to to lead in effect
um and
this means that he is
almost entirely reliant on television he
doesn't have the infrastructure within
the party uh to build a campaign uh and
i do think that even as uh entertainment
and television has become important by
1972 um we're not talking 2016 uh you're
not able to sort of springboard uh a
television image into a successful
campaign and and also
if we're drawing the the sort of
comparison to 2016 the parties are still
much stronger in in 1972 and so he he
really needs those uh those sort of the
infrastructure within the party
and he doesn't have that so
that's
i think one of
the key reasons of of his facility and
then the other part is that he's really
running uh in a field that's
fairly
fairly crowded already uh and he's
running to be the liberal candidate uh
which means that he's facing mcgovern
he's facing shirley chisholm um
and
then you have more sort of
mainstream hubert humphrey and and ed
muskie
and and the main interest for much of
the liberals is finding the one champion
who can guarantee that uh george wallace
isn't going to be uh
a fact
in determining who who the eventual
nominee is um so i think this also hurts
his uh attempt to
sort of springboard himself into the
nomination via television in that
people who might have been convinced by
his campaign in another context now are
worried and he comes in only in florida
so
mcgovern has sort of a head start as of
being the liberal standard bearer and
and i think this plays into the failure
as well
thanks that's really helpful um i mean
especially well there's a lot of
interesting things in there but just the
kind of notion that the the city
political machines are receding faster
than the party machines so that you know
you can be a
gorgeous movie star et cetera or
whatever you know but if the you know as
a newcomer to the democratic party you
can pull it off on that front um we have
a question in the chat from uh michael
sokolev who asks why do the political
parties institutionally approach hot
button politics via entertainment tv
seeking to co-opt them so differently in
the early 1970s in the late 1960s it
seems like a very quick turnaround in
sensibility
it does and indeed it does
even within
like the
the company of of cvs so in in the late
1960s you you have
robert wood coming in as the new
president and and and fairly uh quickly
engages in the confrontation of this
mother's brother's comedy hour uh where
this mother's brothers well they're gay
to work with uh but they're also driving
uh a radical politics
in the views of
of wood and and it ends up with him not
only canceling the show but firing uh
this mother's brothers and and i think
they eventually sue and win
win the case um
but that's late 1960s and and then only
two years later you have this this very
radical show on television and wood is
being hailed as this genius for bringing
it uh
to to the air and to cbs um so that is
indeed a very
fast turnaround just within uh cbs um
and and i well the reason television
historians has written a lot about this
and the reasons are are uh
in particular this
uh
recognition that you need to find the
right kind of audience not the biggest
uh possible audience so this change in
the business model where you're
recognizing the advertising world
doesn't necessarily value
a
senior citizen living on social security
the same as they value a young
affluent
suburbanite and
so this makes the change possible within
television and and then uh the political
parties um in the late 60s uh
are sort of hesitant i think to engage
directly especially with with these um
variety shows
the smothers brothers but also laugh in
because they're so unpredictable and
then you have nixon in in the 68
campaign going on laughing um
which hubert humphrey doesn't dare do um
and and avoids it
and and the reason nixon does it is
because his old buddy paul keys is the
producer of laughing um so in that way
it's a very safe environment for him uh
to sort of experiment with with new uh
forms and then i think the democrats
just become
really sort of shut out
of television by nixon he's very
uh eager to do press conferences or or
other things like televised addresses
and and you use up that air time because
he's the president um so in in the early
70s democrats are
almost forced to find new ways of
attracting media attention because uh
the doors to the broadcasters are pretty
much shut on them and and this is
something that they fight in in the
courts as well uh on on whether or not
they have the right to to equal time or
to reply uh when the president makes
televised addresses and and so forth um
so i would say that that
the change is
is rapid both within broadcasting and
politics uh but it also reflects this
reality of uh
new innovations in broadcasting and then
within the political world uh
a need to find new avenues uh to get
airtime and media
yeah
attention
think i would add to that the the town
halls that
uh nixon did as he was campaigning
uh
where they're very tightly stage managed
and controlled right and they were sort
of feeding him the questions and the
democrats were kept out and you know and
and you know they were he instead of
running campaign he did campaign ads of
course too but he was doing his own sort
of homemade um
tv shows
and you know why did he do that because
his
media guy rodriguez suggested that this
would be a really great way to promote
himself
and
continue from that
again going back to shutting's
of point about television being
important because important people think
television is important and the
publication of selling of the president
which makes the case that it's really
these uh very choreographed um
television productions that
is the reason nixon wins the election
now uh you can argue about whether
that's the case or not but the fact that
this book by by joe mcginnis makes that
case and becomes so popular means that
tele television becomes all important in
the eyes of the strategists the same way
that nixon's conviction in 1960 that he
lost the election because of television
becomes this driving factor in how he
uses television in 68 so it doesn't
really matter how it was it matters how
they perceived it have been
right right yeah yeah that's that's a
really good way to to put it i mentioned
roger ailes in particular um
to point to the relevance of this work
to later developments and which you
indicate in thinking about you know the
rise of showbiz politics and so on but i
wonder if you could
bring us up to the present in certain
ways um we have a question um
uh in the chat do you think tv has
become nowadays is from aguinaldo melo
uh overheated uh
in mcluhan's contact terms you know of
hot versus cold in other words mcluhan
saw tv as a cold meeting cool medium
right and and he's suggesting that maybe
it is now a hot medium and in light of
recent elections being defined by the
influence of
other media as well and the questions
getting at you know the difference you
know what tv had in the 70s that that
doesn't happen hour um so you you could
talk a bit about
mcluhan if you want but it's also just
an opportunity to bring us from 1972 up
to you know the the last couple of
presidential elections and to think
about
um
you know the long-term implications of
this research that you're doing
right
well i i think that
something that's important to note um
right away is is of course that
television
when you move out of the network era
you have so many more outlets and and so
many more hours to fill uh and and as
it's profit driven uh you look at how
are you going to fill these hours and
especially as as 60 minutes makes
television news profitable and you get
executives demanding that television
news is to be profitable and how that
changes that industry so so by the the
1990s you have
a fairly insightful i think uh
commentary in the new york times that
these shows of crossfire and and
um
i'm i'm blanking on on the name of one
of the other ones uh the mclaugh group
um yeah that these shows
and the concept is is familiar to to all
of us i think where you have like
talking heads uh or
speak
pushing the the liberal side and the
conservative side and then they um in
heated exchanges engage in in these um
often cultural
culture war issues and they're
fairly
cheap to produce compared to to running
a a
new
uh a news business and having the
infrastructure of correspondence and so
forth um and and
my point uh of of the insightful new
york times uh point is that they
recognize that this is
all in the family of today like we've
only changed uh archie bunker into pat
buchanan
but they're still
like the the same um
the same sort of conflict is now
proliferating within television news and
not just television entertainment
and and the same thing with somebody
like uh you know rush limbaugh is also
compared fairly frequently in the late
80s and early 90s to to archie bunker it
moves conversation and then of course as
we go into the the 2000s you have
another person who has been frequently
linked to our chi bunker and that is
is uh donald trump
um who
performs this role of uh a
reactionary voice uh on television and
and
so and and trump makes this very clear
that it's not a question of just
liberals conservatives are as eager to
use television even as they can bash
television for you know showing ellen
coming out of the closet in the 1990s
then you or
dan quayle uh
criticizing murphy brown for for having
a baby without a father
these same
conservative
politicians newt gingrich your rudy
giuliani's your bob dole's are making
cameo appearances on television shows to
sort of
heighten their appeal and so this
development is is a development where
the arena is growing bigger and and it's
even more important to be in the arena
and i think
the last 20 years are showing us
just how
important it is to be constantly
engaging um
with
with the the sort of the culture war
issues and that keeps coming up and and
then to the question briefly on on what
1970s television had that that tv today
doesn't have i think one of the key
differences
is is of course the
case of
companies uh
that enabled lear to engage these shows
because he was so important for the
network that he really
uh
really enjoyed unique uh leeway and and
even prominent producers like carr
reiner
couldn't have the same influence uh
or like the the permission to engage
issues in the same way uh which
we saw with the the new dick dykes show
um
so that's one thing and then the other
thing is is the immediacy of all in the
family so they're writing the episodes
and weeks later they're shown to
you know a third of the population
uh that's something that that i connect
strongly with with the success of of all
the family in
outside of of television the success
sort of in in the culture in the
politics and and of course today the
production time of scripted television
entertainment is so much longer and the
audience is so much smaller that you
can't necessarily reach
you know beyond the show
in the way that norman lear and all the
family was able to do and instead you
get a situation where
you know fox news
99 of americans are not watching fox
news on any given sunday and yet it's
able to be such an important factor in
political conversations
because of how outrageous it
outrageously it engages the issues and
then sort of forces political
journalists
to take it seriously and thus inflates
its role in in american politics today
and then you know if something quite
outrageous or when something ever
quite already just happens on fox news
it's going to be recirculated
in
pieces via social media in ways that are
harder to count than a viewing audience
to fox so that we can't always just say
well there's x number of people watching
fox and therefore
you know if that number of people
doesn't vote for this candidate like you
you can't you those causal relationships
are always difficult but when you can't
actually chart
all of the circulation of that material
because it goes beyond tv
um it makes it very hard to to gauge to
gather data and to kind of figure out
what's going on right
right and and and that's all
even even the clip i i showed of all in
the family it was uploaded by the the
production company so they're they're
even today like pushing these old shows
um into on onto youtube and and thus
reaching audiences and again and again
um and and
this infrastructure the media
infrastructure
has changed
so enormously since the 1970s that uh
the conversations
and you of course see this on on shows
that they're very
uh aware of how they can reach beyond
the actual show and especially
you know variety shows or talk shows uh
where they're clearly pushing certain
clips from the shows uh on onto social
media and thinking here of something
like late night with seth meyers where
you have the closer look become a
phenomenon or or you have jordan clipper
uh doing those trump rally interviews
become a phenomenon separate from the
actual broadcast show
yeah and i mean it's great to bring up
late night because then you get into it
circles back to what you're saying about
production time changing and how you
know scripted shows production time has
gotten so much longer so how do you
respond to contemporary events and be
immediately sailing whereas late night
because of the constant churn of
production can pull in things that
immediately as they happen and put them
out and you know in entertainment the
only example i can think of that would
be even close to that would be south
park where they can actually really get
stuff on the show
right away not only always to great
effect and it's not always smart when
it's smart it's very smart but they can
be because the the production is so
cheap and kind of quickly generated
because of the kind of animation they're
doing
they can sort of
be on top of
new things happening much more quickly
than almost any other show and
last we're running out of time but i
just wanted to say like we didn't
you started to get issues that were
thinking about on the family
specifically
in the context of the tv industry
uh
and changes and so on and so first
there's like the issue of production
time changing uh and turn around of
episodes there's the issue of ownership
and just like regulations that enable
independent production companies to
exist and without those regulations the
companies don't exist so that you know
now the only the closest thing to an
independent tv production company that
you know owns its own product is
basically dick wolf who i don't think
most of us would think of as a scrappy
little independent along the lines of
mtm but he owns all of his shows right
um
and the third thing i would just say and
this gets us
uh
into like genre issues and the kind of
into the weeds of tv studies in a
certain way is just thinking about
changes in the sitcom
and the kind of not just like the rise
of the realicon but just thinking about
uh
the move from episodic to seriality
uh within comedy right not just within
drama which is the most
obvious go-to um and just pointing to
like the fact that edith or
conceptualizations of edith you know
sort of shifted over the life of the
series points to something that that was
happening that was sort of radical even
as on the surface the show had a reset
every week like every episodic sitcom
did every week and i think we could also
point to the mary tyler moore show doing
a similar um
kind of thing where i'm just noting that
by season three
the character the characters are
evolving so much and mary has become
like they're dealing with the fact that
she's the only woman who works in the
newsroom
explicitly pretty often
and she learns that the previous
producer in her uh
uh position got 50 less a week in you
know 1972 that's a lot of money um then
she did and and her boss lou grant says
it's because you're a woman you know and
that like that is a change in the
political orientation or shift in the
orientation of the series um
that is both over and subtle at the same
time so anyway if we put on the family
in sort of context of the history of
genre
it it even adds another really
interesting complicated layer to what
we're what you're talking about
um
absolutely
and and all in the family and and the
mary tyler moore show uh
the maritime moore show actually
premieres
a couple of months uh earlier than all
in the family and and there's always um
over the 1970s there's this
understanding that these two shows
represent
sort of both represent quality
television but different forms of
quality television whether mary tyler
moore show is is perhaps less directly
engaging in
somebody would say that all the family
is the shouting version of the mayor
alan moore show that everything is is uh
as norman lear would say living at the
top of our lungs and the end of our
nerves um
and and that
that distinction um is is important but
on the family also um obviously as the
popular show on television it gets all
of these
imitators uh and also spin-offs that
that
the tendon productions are able to to
produce and and sell
but i would say that it's important also
to look at like developments in in
production techniques so what norman
leary is doing is is for example
doing it on video tape
because it's cheaper
or the way he's uh going back to an
earlier era of multi-camera
shows or or the way uh they're doing two
sort of run-throughs and then cutting
the show out of that so bringing sort of
the the stage tradition uh back to
television and and these
these uh innovations linger and then uh
as we get into the 21st century you can
see this again this same pattern with
something like the office then having
this enormous influence on these
mockumentary type shows um
and and it's not just a question of
popularity it's also a question of like
how is this working on our bottom line
like what are we
why are we turning to these innovations
and and how are we benefiting from doing
it so i i think always when we're
talking about television is really
important to keep in mind like people
are are getting
the main point of this is to sell soap
right and people are getting money
all right well we've we've now hit our 6
30 uh threshold um
like a tv show it's time to to sign off
um thank you so much again oscar and
thank you all of our
graduate students um for coming and our
our outside attendees and so on um it
was great and um
[Music]
thanks again
thank you all